speaking of punishment before we get
into the mailbag iran is threatening to
assassinate
donald trump and mike pompeo
take a look at this this video take a
listen
so this is being released by the supreme
leader of iran
showing this military operation very
high tech all these iranian operatives
working on their computers they've got
drones they've got little
little machines outside of mar-a-lago
trump and pompeo are playing golf there
going all around they're gonna they're
gonna target them they put they put the
light they put the focus on trump and
pompeo
eventually what happens you get the
point eventually what happens is they
assassinate them
this
video that iran released
shows two things
shows one that they probably can't
assassinate trump and they're not going
to do it because if they were going to
assassinate trump they'd just
assassinate him
but they can't do that so they're going
to try to release some
b-level hollywood video showing their
their fantasy about killing trump two it
shows that they consider trump the enemy
and biden the friend biden ostensibly is
the president of the united states
shouldn't they be going after him if
they're going to retaliate for an action
of the united states no they're going
after trump because they consider trump
the enemy and biden the friend because
trump treated iran like a rogue state
and biden is trying to suck up to iran
and biden is trying to reinstate the
iran deal
shows you
the way
that
our american politics is looking right
now shows you the way that our foreign
policy is looking and it shows you
something else iran is impotent at the
moment to kill donald trump iran is
impotent to fulfill its agenda
joe biden is impotent on that front too
got to ring that bell
that's that's how you're going to get
the notifications when the new videos
come out
probably the best way actually is you go
to apple podcast spotify stitcher or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show
subscribe
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you